On Judy's way home from
school yesterday, she
ran for half the distance.
Then she skipped for 1/4
of the remaining distance
and walked the rest
of the way home.
She walked for a total 360 feet.
What is the distance between
school and Judy's home?
And they say write the
answer in the yards.
So this is a little
tricky right over here.
They say, 360 feet, write
the answer in yards.
And we have to remind
ourselves that one yard is
equal to 3 feet.
So just so we make sure we don't
make that careless mistake,
let's put all of our
information in yards right now.
So 360 feet is how many yards?
Well there's 3 feet per yard.
So we're just going to
divide 360 feet by 3.
And so 360 divided
by 3 is 120 yards.
And now we can do the whole
problem in terms of yards.
So let's think about it.
So let me say that this
is her entire distance.
This is on her way
home from school.
And then let me draw a line that
shows the distance all the way
home.
So I want to draw this
as large as possible,
so we have room to
write inside of it.
So that's school.
And that is home.
And they first tells us that
she ran for half the distance.
So let's split this in two.
Let's split that in two.
And so she ran for
half the distance.
This is the distance
that she ran.
It's half the total distance.
Then they say, then
she skipped for one
fourth of the
remaining distance.
So let's be clear,
the remaining distance
is what I haven't
filled in orange yet.
So let's mark that off into
fourths of the remaining
distance.
So that is half the
remaining distance.
That's just 1/4, 2/4, 3/4.
So we took the
remaining distance
and we divided it into fourths.
And they say, then
she skipped for 1/4
of the remaining distance.
So this is the remaining
distance after running.
She skipped for 1/4 of it.
And then she walked the
rest of the way home.
So she walked to the
rest of the way home,
this is the distance
that she walked.
And this distance right
over here is 120 yards.
What is the distance between
school and Judy's home?
So there's a bunch of ways that
you could think about this.
When we talked about
the remaining distance
after running, so this
was the remaining distance
after she ran, after this
orange part right over here.
You see that this
blue section is
3/4 of that remaining distance.
120 yards is 3/4 of
this remaining distance.
So this is equal to 3/4
of the remaining distance.
So how much is 1/4 of each
of those remaining distance?
Well since this is 3/4, 1/4
is going to be 1/3 of this.
1/3 of 120 is 40.
So this distance
right over here is 40.
This is 40.
Notice 40 plus 40
plus 40 is 120.
And this right over here
is also going to be 40.
These are all in terms of yards.
So the remaining distance is
going to be 40 times 4 or 160
yards.
So this is 160 yards.
Now, what is the total distance?
Well this 160 yards,
the remaining distance
after she ran, that's half
of the total distance.
So this is 160
yards, then this is
going to be 160 yards as well.
So 160 yards plus 160 yards?
Gives us a total distance from
school to home of 320 yards.